these don't be mad at these dude like
down up whites
do you like the climbing rope on them
that's all I care about so loes rock
warm directly to piss you know but due
to have climbing rope on my shoes
because what happens is that their
regular laces your shoes go flying off
you got climbing rope and now not only
can you climb in those [ __ ] things
but they double cuz you can take them
off if you run out of rope but also
they're never coming off your feet in a
street fight
because when I kick somebody in the
[ __ ] head sometimes and I miss them
my foot goes flat my shoe goes flying
also start with the off-white also I'm
things are going bad wanna off yourself
okay well Epstein's they're well done
lips those the abstains yep now I like
that those are called the Epstein's both
white Epstein's there's the off-white
Epstein's they're also they're also good
for tying off if you wanna if you want
to shoot up oh right I didn't think
about that or someone now I know it's
[ __ ] Rock Monday so I'm gonna go here
you can also tie to the base so you can
tie your piece off at the base and then
take a picture of it well you take a
picture of a batik use it hard for quite
a while
mmm that's a trick in the gay community
I don't know if you know this also in
the porno community right sure but
mostly the gay community what you want
to do is you want to shave everything
down and you want to put a [ __ ] ring you
want to cinch it around not just the
shaft but around the hole the hole
that's right whole unit what you bring
them you don't bring it I want to call
it a unit not a unit well nothing like
you you you put the whole rubberband on
the three pieces in it the three piece
set cause it keeps it from looking like
a baby bird look at that baby bird we're
dealers it'll keep it ten-hut so you get
yourself going a little bit then you tie
off he's always gonna stay a little bit
yes we're saying what we want to do is
you want to take you want to you want to
wrap the whole enchilada mm-hmm then
here's the big trick you wear some
sweatpants know those old school
champion sweatpants right gray no you
don't have underwear on yes now you just
you're flopping around inside a new club
that's right now you're just walk around
here like that guys dong is pressing
against that cotton Hill yeah now girls
would be like gross but they can't stop
staring at it
I am told you the story I had a guy do
that in New York when I'm walking my dog
I had my dog leash and he had a dick he
had his he's do
with his I was like your dick is your
dick is your talking me and your dick is
at a three-quarter mast right now you're
3/4 so just all right then I'm you're
kind of a big guy I'm a big guy in your
mouth - salivating no no it's the
morning and I'm immediately this guy's
trying to pick me up when he goes you
got kids so when you say I'm young - I'm
probably 25 well I'm gonna ask you right
I don't say no watch how quickly watch
watch this ready you got kids
no yeah black guy oh no I think he was
more Latin oh oh might have been
something even deeper like Latin but
maybe Bulgaria Romania with dark scary
and a long line of Ottoman blood got
some [ __ ] in the met that's like just
rates up is slow yeah with a heavy with
a heavy piece and just a big a big a big
heavy body just a lot of mass a lot of
bone and muscle to move around when you
build it he's making a move on and when
he say didn't you put but you did give
him a balls in mouth yeah well no that's
that's my that was man digging your
balls in mouth he was in my acting class
and he was a drag queen and no no that
was a different thing and I'll tell you
something at the end of a I might be a
coward because I held my dog tight I had
a gerbil clinched up on that leash oh
that was a rough one because that was
the same day that my dog grabbed a a rat
later that night he I went back there
cuz I was like if that guy says
something again I'm gonna [ __ ] tell
him I'm like dude you know you think
your thing about the whole day yeah I
don't like being punked because I got
punked a little bit kind of it was big
and then I went back there and my dog
grabbed ahold of a big old rat Chauncey
Chauncey patty stock great named
Chauncey is a great dog Corvino fighting
lines she could hang from a rope for 40
minutes she'd hang from her open for 40
minutes her whole body she was a [ __ ]
crazy pitbull whatever you think of the
pitbull she's made of
alligator that I mean she was I she was
now a typical pitbull correct they're
bad for business
she grabbed a hold of a big rat about
the size of chin I mean a giant rat like
just the biggest thing I got circling
the sides of a small dog Master Splinter
New York rat well fed shook that [ __ ]
in half shook it in half and a piece of
the guts hit me right in the lower lip
second game
yeah I'm still I'm still cleaning my
lips dude I like seeing a rat yeah I
like when I'm go to New York and say I'm
just gonna see a rat they're [ __ ] to
you what does a thing saw like a rat in
the wild they're cool to see man you
like god damn you know they're just the
ultimate survivalist they're just making
afraid car 24/7 yeah yeah yeah yeah
watch your tongue oh good what's gonna
happen what are you gonna do use some of
that boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]